she has starred in such films as to die
for and the portrait of a lady Nicole
Kidman
editing provides us with the rhythm and
pace of the film it puts the move in
movie into cutting the film scene by
scene towards its conclusion whatever
the tempo swift or slow the editor
transfixes us by putting together a
world where our movie ticket is our
passport in many ways it's like the
dance moving back and forth at a
particular pace always pushing deftly
and percussively to its climax the
nominees for best achievement in film
editing are Walter Murch for the English
Patient gerry hambling for Evita
Roderick James for Fargo Joe Hutchins
for Jerry Maguire Pitt Carmel for shine
and the Oscar goes to
Walter Murch for the English Patient
no matter how true it may be that film
is a collaborative medium English
patient took that to a new level with a
team of filmmakers that were assemble
from eight countries and five continents
but instigating all of that and then
harnessing that energy was souls ants
and Anthony Minghella and Michael
Ondaatje - Who am I eternally grateful
for the ability to work on this film I
also want to thank my crew Danny Farrell
and rosemary Conte Edie blamin Pat
Jackson for some associate editing I
want to thank my my wife the patient
English Aggie and my son the half
English Patient Walter and my daughters
Beatrice Carey and Connie thank you very
much
more Oscar excitement when we return
with Debbie Reynolds Glenn Close and
Gregory Hines